she's from Knoxville Tennessee and she's
the grower of the world's longest mullet
she's verified and yeah damn baby she
could grow grapes on that thing my God
Tammy manace Tammy manace nice to see
you today thank you so much for having
me yeah congratulations on you got that
scalp lava baby you got all of it i'
I've got it all fluffy today God and
what you taking it for a walk is that a
kind of a the way you set it for a
Sunday or is there How does it go
throughout the week the the the hair
care how is it it it it does not frol it
freely during the week but uh I have my
friend with me this weekend I have a
family get together and so we can
coordinate with doing this and the
getting it Reb braided I have to keep it
braided because otherwise uh by the end
of the day my tail is dragging all of my
tails are dragging because it's actually
longer than I am oh wow so you've really
outdone yourself literally it's one of
those things it's like really you tried
to do that no just life happened I Haven
have it yeah did you get forgetful were
you in a coma or something how'd you get
it that long how long is
it it is 68 inches long when it's fully
stretched out I'm only 64 inches tall
okay so there you go you Val yeah wow
that's so long and do you get scared
like you cuz you it must be a little
risk in there huh like if you you know a
mistake you're a box fan or something
like that and you your your afternoon
could change you being a neck brace I I
I know where my tail is I'm pretty ta
aware now okay so and like I said it
stays in a braid so and where I work I
usually wear a back brace because I'm
old and it tames the tail okay I see and
when I sit down it's funny my nurse
manager she actually says I laugh every
time you sit down to draw blood because
I automatically just throw it over my
left leg oh yeah it's like I know where
it is that's beautiful yeah there's
something lovely about that you know
does it almost does it almost feel like
a pet does it almost feel like a friend
or something oh no not a
bit it's just it's something I've had
for 33 and a half years now so yes it is
a part of me yeah oh yeah I can imagine
well you know I have a just a starter
kit going on the on the back of my head
but I um hey dude you got a mullet
you're good well we'll see you know I it
feels like me once my hair got longer it
just felt like me it was like oh this is
where I'm always supposed to be this is
the way I've my head is supposed to have
been do you feel most comfortable with
your hair like that like would you feel
very out of sort you think if you had to
take it
off I I saw something once and somebody
had just come up and cut somebody's hair
and it made me
nauseous wow I actually had a tail prior
to this one uh back in 80
89 and I cut it and it was only you know
probably about five or six inches which
I still have oh yeah and I immediately
felt this angst I was like okay that
ain't gonna happen so February 9th 1990
I started growing this one so yes it has
a birthday
yeah so how old is it it is 33 and a
half it'll be 34 years February the 9th
praise God baby and if we plucked a
strand of it or a cord of it and we
tested it would it what would it test
positive for you got a long well I
always told I told everybody I couldn't
do drugs in my life because you can
literally do a drug test on hair and I
would have been in so much trouble but
I've been a good girl I don't do that
stuff oh yeah yeah yeah damn boy because
yeah I think yeah there's just so much
of it you'd really be able to just kind
of you could probably find the exact
Friday night that you smoked a joint if
somebody wanted to get real particular
on there how what is your mother think
of it what does she think of your long
hair and your world record now because
you you're in the record books aren't
you yes I I I actually have my beautiful
tenis world record book here yeah that's
so cool I yeah I said I've I've um show
me your page let me see what page you're
on Wow
shorty that's
awesome but back to my mom I said
somebody made a negative comment once
and they said oh they must be so proud
and I said well actually my mom's
probably up in heaven looking down
laughing her butt off now yeah my mom
pass away a few years ago but yeah I
think she would think it was hilarious
oh that's cool yeah she's probably
getting a good laugh out of it oh oh
yeah she probably be like well it's just
your hair I'm like yes mother now do
people what are what are some of the
nicknames you got like maybe I was
trying to think of something maybe Billy
Ray punzel maybe or I'm trying to think
of I like that one really runzel I think
I probably started mine before he had
his no it's just it's just it's just a
tale everybody knows me for my hair I
mean people can't remember my name but
they go I want the one long hair yeah
and it was it was so funny because when
I was on um deployment with the state
guard during coid I was in uniform all
the time so after I got off Co and I got
hired at the health department I didn't
have to have my hair tucked anymore
because I did in uniform and the people
were just
like you've always had that I said yeah
I just knew how to hide it wow
so yeah you never know what people are
hiding these days boy somebody you never
know oh yeah I work in public health
tell me about it God damn yeah dude you
never know somebody will show you a mold
that they can piss out of you know you
just know it's just a weird world out
there I tell people I could strangle you
and they'd be looking for a rope okay
yeah now we're talking huh you you ever
done any light crime with it Tammy oh no
I mean it's like you know with all the
people out in the world you know the
hair and everything N I don't need that
career
yeah um what about any long-term plans
with with it if you considered maybe
doing uh Locks for Love or or locks for
lust even hell I'd buy a damn half a
foot make a damn orgy towel out of it or
something I mean I bet you gotta realiz
you the thread that's what I was saying
somebody said you know about only fans
you know feet hair I said no no no I I
have a I like to keep a decent image um
no I've had people say so are you gonna
cut it now and I told the uh news person
I said let me think about that no yeah
I'm very blessed because not everybody's
hair will grow long that's that's a
great Point set point that's a great
point so you're almost doing it for the
people that can't do it even there's a
little bit of that in there sure sure
we'll go with that and now when you say
if you go to heaven one day right and
you uh what where you does the hair go
with you does
it um I hope somebody's up there that
can braid it for me oh yeah because I
can't do it by myself I have to have
somebody do it for me now that's kind of
interesting you have to have a partner
really to get to keep that hair well yep
and she's been in some of the videos
that Guinness put out because they they
did a whole photo shoot which was really
cool yeah and they've done different
videos and I found a lot of them online
I mean because this story got out which
was
amazing and I mean some of the people's
got the video of the my brother who is
more technological than I am he actually
filmed a whole thing where she took it
down and he did it in fast motion and
then we did a whole time of rating it CU
it takes her about an hour and 15
minutes to braid it by the time she yeah
by the time she braids it and rewraps it
cuz I put a little crochet floss at the
top keep from getting so fuzzy put
little beads on the end oh damn I think
you getting it ready for church huh and
what kind of Sab you put in it you put
any Sav or something in it what do you
guys do over there well you know I joked
with somebody because they asked uh are
you got any hair care product promos I
said no but I'm a already made
commercial for Main and tail hair and
conditioner come on oh yeah oh I bet
half the Preakness gets [__] pissed
if you walk by they get re Them Ponies
will show out I'm sure yeah it's
actually a pretty good product but I've
used several things through the years
but I like stuff with Argan I have
shampoo condition and then um leave in
conditioner right before she braids it
oh that's beautiful God that's Beau and
it gets it gets re braided about once a
week m m it sounds it sounds damn
Majestic really sounds Royal it really
do I don't know if I if you see it it
comes all the way up oh yeah God oh yeah
I'm like if I if I can get you it's kind
of hard to show the whole thing just I
get it baby of it l oh my God yeah it
kind of fluffy you tell the Irish in me
there with the reddish oh yeah oh sure
yeah um I people say that's impressive
I'm like okay thank you now you ever
caught a lover on it you ever put a
little chicken liver on the end of it or
a butterscotch or something and just
kind of you you got a little toe line
for you there I know no but I I'm always
careful if I'm around
cats because I think it's a building cat
toy right there oh they do don't they
they don't have a heart do
they it's something I've dealt with so I
know how to deal with it but yeah it's
um it's a it's a conversation piece yeah
well it sure is well it brought us here
to talk to you today Tammy and I just
want to say thanks yeah a for just doing
something unique you know it's fun to do
something unique in your life and and
people don't realize there's all types
ways to find some way to be creative or
to be expressive and uh I think that's
just such a nice reminder um and I'm
just who I am that's what I tell
everybody I said I just try to be nice
do my job well and and one I had did one
negative comment well one I had several
when all this came out and people were
making some negative comments and I'm
like they talking about the state of the
world I said yes I'm in healthcare I
understand how the world is if this
gives somebody something to smile at
laugh about make fun
something different oh yeah if it takes
your mind off of stuff going bad that's
fine with me I'm good with it oh you
could stand by any River in Louisiana
and you could charge a nickel every time
somebody want a rope swing off into that
thing honey I'll say that I wish I could
make a nickel off every time somebody
made a comment about it I really now
that's fair that's he look that hair
tariff baby that's it look that that
counts um is there a Meetup is there a
Meetup for the Guinness World Record
holders do you guys do an event do you
get to meet the guy with the longest uh
tooth or the sharpest elbow or the you
know the guy who's been underwater for a
month or whatever like is there a um you
know is there any not that I know of I
know there's mullet meetups yeah people
have different that I am that's for
drugs so let's just call that is I might
had to turn that job down as a judge
next year I was asked about well look
the I just saying the ones at the rest
area are I'll tell you that that's for
sure yeah God bless those people yeah we
just wanted to say hey Tammy you know we
know there's been a lot of hype and
hoopla and um and I've gotten I've
gotten tagged in so many pictures
wanting us to say hey to you and and get
to spend a little bit of time so just
want to say congrat yeah congratulations
and thank you so much for uh for
chatting with us today we appreciate
you I know my brother's thrilled because
when I first got the invitation we
couldn't hook up and I was my brother
was checking on my social media actually
gave him the passwords and he goes oh my
God I missed the invitation from Theon
I'm like I don't have time to check all
this stuff so I was looking you up and
I'm like oh crap all those people I'm
gonna be the most boring interview he's
ever done and he wants to talk to me
okay n you're great you're you're doing
something unique you know I could you
know I don't have anything you know I'm
not going to say I never been the owner
of anything long but you know I never
really you know
God God gave me what he gave me you know
and that's fine with us so somebody said
you know other people have long hair I
said I know people who can sing but
they're not on the voice yeah it's just
how lucky you get with what you got y
well you I'm thankful and I'm happy amen
I like your attitude happy holidays to
you Tammy and thank you for your time
tonight you as well keep your mullet
going keep it trim you're good yeah I'll
see you maybe I might see you in the
mullet streets next year all right hey
take care thank you so much you too
darling bye bye bye thank you Tammy not
often you get to talk to this real Vine
of society right there just one
of God just one of Mother Nature's damn
just just a fern of
beauty oh that's beautiful that tail boy
you hang that thing out of window at
night boy seven
runil hump it baby God praise God thank
you
Tammy